sir right oh thank you fabiola
uh so welcome to the star joint
committee meeting
um we have members in attendance here
from all of the member authorities
and officers additionally with star
staff
uh and our uh help administration help
from trafford
so propose to start the agenda um on the
point for
attendance are any apologies for absence
apologies received from nikki bishop
thank you
minutes is gender item two to receive
the minutes
held on the 17th of june do we do that
we
agreed thank you and declarations of
interest for any members
no if not if you find out later can you
let us know through the usual channels
um urgent business if any i haven't been
made aware of any
um so i'd like to move on to the
quattron progress report
okay that been me
thank you nicole um fabioli are you
sharing it on the screen or just talk
through it
i can show you on the if you make a
start i'll i'll uh
show on the screen okay thank you
so i'm just going to talk you through
the quarter one um performance report
for star
these reflect the new measures that were
agreed at the last
joint committee meeting and now all our
performance reporting is done through
the tableau system
which you'll find the extract from that
in appendix one
of the report the key things i just want
to draw your attention
to are under the commercial under
savings
we've achieved 700k so far in quarter
one
which is less than what we would have
hoped for at this stage
but i just want to flag that that
doesn't include any savings from
ten side as at this moment because we're
struggling with resources
at tame side to get those signed off due
to um other covid type commitments
um so we are still confident that we are
going to reach our 5.6 million pound
target and we are doing some focus work
around savings and working very closely
with your finance teams
to be more proactive on this because
obviously we understand the significant
financial pressures
that all of you have got so that will
continue to be an absolute
priority for us in terms of
income that is showing at the moment at
the end of quarter one as 74k
i'm pleased to say that since then we've
had additional income coming
as well so that's now up to more like
100k
works coming in mainly from gmca some
work with tlc
also further afield we've had some
income secured from coventry
council for a second phase of some work
we've been doing on their
coroner's and mortuary review so
we did further in quarter one there were
very few sort of income opportunities
due to covid
but increasingly there's more
opportunities coming forward and more
tendering that we're
doing so we are still confident again
that we will achieve that 150k
target in terms of social value
um the social value target is 25
and we're at 24.1 so we're very close to
achieving that target
and there was a slight dip as you can
see from the graphs in quarter one
we putting that down to the market being
quite cautious
due to covered and being unclear about
how much social value they could commit
during all the uncertainty
because in response to that as we talked
about the last committee meeting we have
implemented the covered plugin so people
so
organizations can select to do specific
covered
social value so i'm hoping that by
quarter two
that that percentage will have increased
and local spend our targets at 50 and as
you can see we're now above target on
that and actually quarter one
performance was very high
over 60 percent so we are exceeding our
target on that but we will continue to
work hard on this objective and carry on
implementing our 10-point
sme and local business support plan that
we have previously shared with you
the last one is around compliance and
that is around the on-contract spend
so the target for this is at 90 percent
so we're very close
again to achieving that target and we
now have a monthly process in place to
review all
off contract spends so we are expecting
those percentages to
increase as we move through the year as
well
so that's quick run through are there
any questions on that
thank you very much dickler any
questions anyone
council mcgee thank you chad so perhaps
more
than a question i'm guessing that if you
look at the three graphs on the right
hand side they all show
sort of comparable almost the same level
of over the quarter
and i think what you see there is as you
say the
the sort of uncertainty that everybody
was facing
so um on that basis given where you've
got to
i think that's a reasonable you know
reasonable position at this stage in the
year uh i mean if we were
that at the end of the financial year we
might think differently but
currently given everything i think
that's reasonable so i wouldn't unduly
worry at this stage
um what would be more interesting i
think is quartz uh you know
the half year figures
thank you nichola do you want to come
back on that or are you
content with the college yeah so yeah
i'm happy with those comments we will um
at the beginning of the next month so by
the time we come back to
joint committee i think it's early
december we should have that half year
position
ready for you thank you council allah
did you have your
hand up did i see
no no okay i think you might be on mute
yeah yeah i am unmuted and i didn't have
my end up all right no worries
no okay thank you very much nichola are
we happy to
note that then yep i'm not seeing any
any other hands so that's fine
item six the new star business plan for
2023
that's me again fabulous um
this is um pleased to present a copy of
our new draft business plan for 2020 to
23.
and this replaces the current one that
we've got at the moment that's been in
place for three years
we're very proud to say that our
business plan isn't a document that just
sits on a shelf it is
absolutely ingrained in what we do
everything from our category strategies
through to our performance staff
performance reviews it's absolutely
embedded into what we do
and similarly we hope that our new
business plan will be exactly the same
so what we have done is refreshed and
updated the business plan we've
had discussions with yourselves with
starboard and with the team
and so what we're presented with today
is the updated business plan
we've um got the five c's but we have
we've kept the first three as per the
last business plan
but the there's the two new ones so
replacing compliance
is now confidence which is all about us
providing you with confidence in the
service that we're delivering
as well as the compliance and then the
other one is replacing champions with
courage
which has got much more stronger
emphasis on innovation
and trying new and better ways of
working
we've also added in the four enablers
that you'll see in the
in the business plan so
what we've got there now is a final
draft and what we're hoping for if you
approve the contents today is to then
delegate um
final approvals because it does need
just some final editing it needs
formatting it needs using up into a more
professional document
um ready for launching in october
any questions thank you nichola
any questions on item six
council mcgee
i've got council ross as well by
bringing in after council mcgee
thank you for that so um in the forward
there's a sort of uh
there's a an oblique reference to um to
revise staffing so
uh i'm just be interested in you know
what that what that uh
what benefits that will give us and um
slightly facetiously i can see you've
got to be courageous
as one of your um is one of your strap
lines
it reminds me of the one take courage
which of course is a
london brewery um so maybe maybe you
maybe you took some solace from that who
knows
nicholas you have to come back on that
that is the forward i think that was um
that was the reigns
if you want to come in there lorraine
yes i will do thanks nicolette yes i'll
i'll take the responsibility firstly i'm
a wine drinker not a beer drinker
counselor mcgee so
definitely has no courage um
your first point was about staffing um i
think and and i think what we're trying
to aspire to is we're always reviewing
and the resource that we have um within
the team
we're very much into promoting um star
being the employer of choice because one
one thing we do have is as a
staff um cohort that
we have massive retention we have little
turnover we invest heavily
in um development both informally and
formally with sips training
so for me it's about making that
workforce be at the hub of everything
that we do
and we have a flexible workforce that if
we secure commissions
we look at capacity because procurement
has peaks and troughs as you will know
along the way so
it's about how we flex and utilize and
skill our workforce to be the very best
and to respond
and grow with the organization and we
want to be the procurer of choice we
want to be the employer of choice or
continue to be the employer of choice so
that's the emphasis
really around and the people piece in
the full word
hopefully that responds to your points
president
thank you no that's useful because to be
honest
i think organizations now that aren't
nimble and swift on the feet
um are aren't going to survive too long
so
you know that that sort of revised
structure is almost inevitable
i think across lots of innovative
organizations
because we have to adapt as we go along
to the changing circumstances
okay thank you councillor ross
yeah sorry
again more of a comment than a question
um as a business plan
i just thought it read really well was
very concise and got over all the
messages that need to so
thank you very much for that it was uh
it was a pleasure to read it i do like
the uh the updates that you've made
thank you council ross i think nicholas
just responded there so we're okay
are there any more comments or questions
on the business plan
item or anything else anyone wants to
raise
no okay so are we happy to
agree that business plan
yes i'm not seeing any hands to the
contrary so i think we we agree that
thank you
that's agreed okay so
um we've got
a date and time of the next meeting for
gender item seven
which just confirms that the next
meeting is on wednesday the 16th of
december
of this year uh it's likely to be
virtual
um i'm now going to put a motion to the
committee uh
that we exclude the press and public uh
from the meeting so that we can deal
with a confidential item before the
close of the meeting
um do people agree that motion
yes yes yes okay
thank you so i will close the meeting
there for the public
and then i'll wait a moment while the
webcast finishes and then we'll continue
with the agenda